[Música]
y
sí
ah
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el año 1992
la epidemia del vih/sida se llevaba a
uno de mis amigos
por aquel entonces yo no tenía muy bien
claro cómo era posible que mi amigo se
fuese
y esto generó una especial voracidad de
mi parte para tratar de entender cómo
era posible que estuviera sucedido qué
pasaba con esta epidemia
en aquel momento todo material que
llegara sobre el sida y que caía en mis
manos era motivo de lectura y me
encuentro con una frase
qué es la frase que me conecta con el
miedo con la angustia pero por sobre
todas las cosas con la necesidad de
hacer
la frase decía en los años por venir
occidente asistir a la africanización de
la epidemia esto significa que se van a
infectar se van a enfermar y se van a
morir fundamentalmente
yo tengo una hija depositaria de el amor
más inmenso
que por aquel entonces tenía un juego
conmigo y jugábamos a que yo la
alcanzaba y ella corría y yo nunca le
cansaba propósito
después de esto
tuve la necesidad de alcanzarla
abrazarla
para que nada le pasara
este fue el pilar inicial de una ong que
nació allá por el 92 93 que seamos
adolescentes contra el sida
no teníamos claro que íbamos a hacer
pero teníamos en claro que queríamos
hacer algo y nos digo nos que no
solamente formó parte de esta ong no soy
solo yo sino que por ella pasaron un
montón de chicos un sinnúmero de chicos
coincidimos en que lo que había que
hacer era educar y nos encontramos con
esa frase maravillosa de nelson mandela
que decía
la educación es el arma más poderosa
para cambiar el mundo y queríamos
cambiar ese mundo para que por lo menos
en nuestra jesús-maría no hubiese sida y
yo quería para que mi jesús maría no mi
hija estuviera lo más protegida posible
cuando la gente dice que generoso lo
tuyo no no esto partió de un de algo
diría yo
demasiado mío como era proteger a mi
hija
nos encontramos con frases como esta
buceamos es lo que significa significaba
la enfermedad
en la gente que causaba la enfermedad en
los mecanismos de transmisión
y nos topamos con temas vinculados con
la sexualidad y entonces nos tuvimos que
rozar con algo que el mundo llama malas
palabras pero este hombre maravilloso
llamado roberto fontanarrosa dijo no
existen las malas palabras lo que
existen son las malas intenciones y
nosotros no teníamos absolutamente
ninguna mala intención en todo esto
queríamos saber para compartir los
conocimientos nos juntábamos con mis
soldaditos de la vida como alguna vez
los bautizó el doctor hugo roland y
entonces nos dedicamos a saber y cuando
empezamos a aprender nos dimos cuenta de
que muchas de las cosas que nosotros
pensábamos que eran ciertas los otros no
la pensaban y que podíamos convivir con
ideas diferentes
y estoy hablando de la sexualidad y
estoy hablando la mirada con respecto a
él al ejercicio de esa sexualidad y si
no miren este ejemplo ambos tienen razón
sin embargo la sociedad tiene una mirada
tan sesgada con respecto a esto que no
fue muy difícil si hoy es difícil hablar
de esto imagina lo que fue hace 25 años
supimos que para contraer el vih solo
hacía falta ser humano y todos somos
humanos y la parte más dolorosa de esta
epidemia es la cantidad de niños
infectados que hay
y entonces como no podía ser de otra
manera en el primer encuentro al que
concurrimos con mis soldaditos de la
vida los 17 fundadores de aces
nos encontramos con nuestro primer
paciente con sida
niño de 4 años que nos dejó marcados de
por vida
nos encontramos con que había
razonamientos no yo la conozco mucho y
entonces vimos esta historia que es por
demás significativa es la historia de
estos dos chicos que intimaron anoche si
cada uno de ellos en el último año
íntimo con tres personas esa noche hubo
ocho personas involucradas en la
relación pero si en vez de considerar un
año para atrás
consideramos cuatro la cantidad de gente
involucrada son 80 y si en vez de
considerar cuatro años consideramos diez
harían falta 728 páginas para publicar
las fotos de toda la gente que estuvo en
esa cama bajac a mano
entonces nos dimos cuenta de algo que
define tan fantásticamente esta
diapositiva cuando íntimas con alguien
no está intimando con una persona está
intimando con la historia de esa persona
y con la historia de las personas que
intimaron con esa persona
tuvimos un enorme un enorme aliado pese
a dichos que han circulado por nuestra
sociedad absurdos y ese aliado fue el
preservativo de látex que no permite que
pase el agua el aire uno no infla y no
se desinfla sin embargo hay gente que
un discurso muy cuestionable lo
cuestionó
fíjense que tuve muchos maestros pero
una de las lecciones más importantes que
tuve fue la que nos dio el vih a este
virus que se llama los de la
inmunodeficiencia humana no le importa
ni el color de mi piel ni la religión
que profesó ni si soy rico ni si soy
pobre ni si me gustan los hombres o me
gustan las mujeres en una epidemia
caracterizada por la discriminación el
gran no discriminador de esta historia
se llamaba vih
cómo contrarrestamos esa discriminación
y la discriminación es el pilar
fundamental sobre el que crece la
epidemia cómo contrarrestamos la
discriminación con esa palabra mágica
pero no solamente que pasa por lo
dialéctico sino que tiene que ver con
las acciones cotidianas la solidaridad y
como bioquímico que soy y como ex
docente que soy de escuela secundaria
recurrí a esta frase maravillosa de uno
de mis maestros que decía
tendríamos que imitar la solidaridad de
la sangre que corre a la herida sin
necesidad de ser llamada como
contrapartida
nos encontramos con esto esto que pasó
durante años y que sigue pasando la
política del avestruz meter la cabeza
para creer que de esto no que por no
verlo no nos va a pasar nada
saben hay tanto tiempo en el que hemos
dado tanta ventaja en la prevención del
vih tomando este tipo de actitudes
bueno nos juntamos con los chicos todas
las semanas en el colegio que nos vio
nacer en ese enorme útero de cemento
llamado colegio domingo faustino
sarmiento con la necesidad absolutamente
indelegable de hacer
alguna vez
pedro cano uno de mis grandes maestros
publicó esta frase todos somos
responsables de lo que no tratamos de
impedir y nosotros salimos a tratar de
impedir lo que vendría
estos son los soldaditos de la vida que
iniciaron la tarea estos son mis héroes
estos son los que dejaron de lado su
tiempo de esparcimiento hasta familiar
para comprometerse en la lucha contra el
vih/sida son los que cada miércoles
ellos se reúnen en el colegio no ellos
porque ellos ya son papás mamá pero son
los que marcaron el camino todos los
miércoles nos juntamos en el mismo
colegio para tratar de saber para tratar
de conocer para tratar de llevar ese
conocimiento para que a nadie más le
pase esto saben me han cuestionado
muchas veces han dicho muchas cosas muy
desagradables
prefiero cientos de padres enojados
porque hemos hablado de este tema porque
he hablado de este tema y no una madre
destrozada porque su hija contrajo el
vih
esto esto fue nuestra última reunión
hace pocos días en la que estuvimos con
los chicos que van al colegio en el
medio invadimos los clubes
invadimos los centros vecinales
invadimos hasta los centros parroquiales
pero fundamentalmente el mensaje llegó a
todas y cada una de las familias de los
chicos de aces y de sus amigos también
el 25 de mayo es un día muy especial
porque hay una enorme actividad en jesús
maría y entonces aprovechamos para
mostrar algo de lo que hacemos el
primero de diciembre es el día más
importante en el mundo en lo relacionado
con la lucha contra el sida y desde hace
seis años realizamos la marcha de las
mil remeras una marcha que goza gracias
a dios' con el apoyo de nuestro
municipio que se ha hecho carne de lo
que hacemos y ese día
convocamos a toda la comunidad y cuando
digo a toda la comunidad digo a toda la
comunidad esto serán seguramente los
futuros soldaditos de la vida en el 2013
dijimos qué bueno que estaría hacer una
una campaña para llamar a la marcha con
esos guantes cuando vimos el precio de
los guantes dijimos qué bueno qué tarea
pero como alguna vez dijo un gran
pensador argentino no te des por vencido
ni aún vencido y entonces que hicimos
nos pintamos y entonces convocamos a
nuestra comuna a sumarse a esta marcha
que lo que pretendía era tratar de
despertar algunas de las tantas
conciencias adormecidas que tenemos en
nuestra sociedad bueno estas son algunas
fotos de esa marcha esta foto está
bárbara porque me permite recordar que
tengo que buscar remera para chicos
estos son los hijos
los nietos que me dio la vida una de las
preguntas más tristes que me han hecho
en mi vida es cuánto ganas no gano nada
pero el todo el dinero del mundo no
llegaría a servir para comprar el amor y
el afecto que siento del que soy
depositario
y esto es para no ser machistas porque
recién los puse a los soldaditos de la
vida y estas eran nuestras futuras
soldaditos de la vida esta fue la marcha
del año pasado fue muy especial porque
iniciamos los 25 años y en la remera
había un montón de fotos de nuestros de
nuestra historia en el lazo rojo
estos son amigos que concurrieron con su
familia la tarea es absolutamente
inclusiva
y estas son las hijas de una de las
fundadoras de ases que como no podía ir
sin el chupete obviamente nos acompañó
con su chupete
se acuerdan de la definición decida que
el sida es una enfermedad que les
organice el sistema de defensa de las
personas o no existe otro sida que es el
que surge de la discriminación el
rechazo y el estigma y se llama sida
social y no está provocado por el vídeo
está provocado por nosotros y causa
mucho más daño
saben cuando yo veo a este dibujo
desde el primer día que lo vi no puedo
dejar de emocionarme
porque recuerdo aquel niño de 4 años que
no necesito pedir pedirnos que lo
abrazamos porque lo hicimos
espontáneamente
este eso él
quien dijo
una huella indeleble en cada uno de
nosotros
y el lazo rojo que ustedes deben haber
visto por todos lados trasciende con
creces un pedazo de tela con un alfiler
acá y compromiso acá y contención
acá y conocimiento acá y solidaridad
pero por sobre todas las cosas hay una
enorme cuota de amor por el prójimo
hemos repartido cientos
miles decenas de miles de lazos rojos a
lo largo de nuestra historia con ases en
cada uno de esos lazos rojos dejamos
nuestro amor
creo en la solidaridad
pues está en hechos concretos no creo en
la cuestión de la palabra creo en el
abrazo como una manifestación
maravillosa de mi solidaridad
no puedo menos que recordar a uno de mis
más grandes maestros el gran paco mateo
que nos debe estar mirando desde arriba
que nos trajo aquella frase maravillosa
que decía somos ángeles de una sola ala
sólo podremos volar abrazado a otro
este es el motor de mi vida
esta fue la que aquel día quería que yo
la alcanzara
hoy me trajo un motor más grande todavía
que termino de mostrarme en mi corazón
es muy chico y que no entra todo el amor
que tengo por él
y en el medio de los dos está mi
compañera incondicional la que me apoyó
en todos los momentos que mi esposa
marta
muchas veces me preguntan cuál es mi
sueño y si sueño con un mundo sin sida
sueño con muchas organizaciones de
chicos trabajando en esto
me re traigo aquel momento en el que el
primer chico entregó ese lazo rojo y en
él su conocimiento su contención su
solidaridad su amor a otro y me parece
que estaría bárbaro que muchos más lo
hicieran para generar una sociedad en
donde el tema se plantee desde el
conocimiento desde la salud y no desde
la enfermedad tal vez esto va tan a
favor del dicho porque no pensarlo al
revés porque no despertar a la
problemática del sida desde la salud
desde la prevención y no tener que
pensarlo cuando apareció el caso tan
cercano de nuestra vida
alguna vez este buen hombre llamado
este buen hombre llamado fray mamerto
menapace dijo venimos a este mundo con
tres consignas la de dejar una huella de
tratar de ser felices y la de aprender a
amar saben no tengo la menor duda de que
con aces dejamos una huella no tengo la
menor duda de que eso lo pudimos hacer
gracias al enorme amor que tenemos por
nuestro prójimo
y no tengan la menor duda de que eso nos
hizo enorme pero enormemente felices
hace un tiempo escuché una conversación
entre san martín y por redone relatada
por un historiador que decía san martín
le dijo a po y redon tenemos que cruzar
la cordillera de los andes y liberar a
chile para que el continente americano
quede libre y por redon le dijo eso es
imposible
y san martín le dijo yo sé que es
imposible pero es imprescindible que lo
intentemos y si intentamos lo
imprescindible
seguramente aquello que parece imposible
deje de serlo
mi sueño mi ilusión sería llegar a todas
y cada una de las cabezas de nuestros
jóvenes y decirles que son importantes
que se tienen que cuidar porque la vida
de ellos es preciosa y porque si no se
cuidan y algo les pasa van a dejar
muerto en vida
me gustaría llegar a cada una de las
conciencias de todos los jóvenes
aunque eso parezca imposible
saben sigo intentándolo sé que es
imposible
pero es imprescindible
que lo sigue intentando porque a lo
mejor si sigo intentando esto que parece
imposible
termine siendo posible
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
y
e
[Música]